I'm waiting for the three guys, I mean Jason, Sean and Will, but I mean I don't know what happened with them, maybe the equipment doesn't work, or maybe everything doesn't work, who knows what's going on here, but welcome to Spotless! Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Jason, what did you do last night? I know what you did. You went to the Lakers game.
Yes, had a great, great time. Really fun. I hosted 3-11-year-olds. One of which was my daughter. Was it fun? time, really fun. I hosted 311-year-olds, one of which was my daughter. Was it fun? It was really fun. Did they win? They did win. They tried to lose, but they fixed it there at the end.
And it was a hoot. I've heard people describe fun things as. That's fun. That's fun. Yeah, I like going to Lakers game. And then today, I was going to do some cooking, but then I heard that I think Sean, maybe you might have mentioned to Amanda that no one's interested in eating what I, or was it you will?
No one's interested in Sean. That's what I was planning on cooking, apparently got kind of a want-want. You, so, wow. And Amanda said what, Amanda said what you were planning on cooking in Sean said nobody wants that. Yeah, I said nobody wants Who wouldn't want yeah, please tell me what a gooey peanut butter chocolate chip bar. Yeah, oh sorry gooey pumpkin chocolate chip bar. Well no the only okay, and then the other thing was yeah That because nobody wants pumpkin and I ran berry lemon bar. No, that's right. Nobody wants pumpkin and anything and nobody wants cranberry and anything.
And apparently the gale said, all of them said that also you can't have lemon in a dessert that was according to our hostess. What? So I guess a real bullet dodged. I guess so. Yeah. You know what all these freaks on the New York Times top 10 desserts, bullet dodged. I guess so. Yeah. You know what, all these freaks on the New York Times top 10 desserts, Lister thinking.
What, what, what, you know what I'm saying? Oh, is that, was that? Wait, but this is like, Amanda said, Amanda said that every year you do this and that you, you like to cook a few things here and there. And I knew nothing about this. I did not either. I didn't either.
I had forgotten, but I guess she says that I, this is what I do every year, but you know, I think I, I bake some stuff because I want to. You inspired me. I want to. Oh, that's good. You inspired me. I was so, like, you've done cheesecake, you've done brownies, you've done, you're going
to do eclare's next week. I think you did last night was good. That little, that thing you did. Oh, last night I did not like that. I made, I made this new thing last night. I didn't love it too much, too sweet. But Jay, I made a box of Mac and cheese last night at 1030 because it's too big of a gummy and I feel like today.
So, after a full dinner, he went home and ate a full box and has a neat and all day because he's been there. I almost took a picture of it and said it's here. I mean, the gummy wiped out. Yeah, I didn't have the gummy wipe out. Still recovering. Listen, I tell you what, I tell you who did not eat an entire box
of mac and cheese last night was our guest. Because this is somebody who has famously taken care of himself his entire life. This is a person who has made a mark in every single thing he's decided to go into in his life. It's pretty hard to have lived in Western culture and not know who this man is. Pretty hard. Do I sound very Canadian when I say that?
I said it almost easily. Or Chicago. Like you from Chicago. This person, his, is such a part of our sort of cultural fabric at risk of embarrassing him when I say that, but it is true. He over the last 40, 50 years, he has been in absolutely every seemingly every walk of life. He has done everything from being an author to being a incredible, one of the biggest film stars ever to being a politician.
He is not, he refuses to be categorized as a self-made man because I think that he claims that he's had a lot of help along the way, but it sure seems like he did a lot. He's done a lot of heavy lifting on his own, especially he did a lot of heavy lifting when he won, I'm gonna say, Senator Tornado. Senator Olympia, he was also a four-time Mr. University, he's also the 38th governor
of the state of California. Got it. Guys, it's Arnold Schwarzenegger. Hello, that's so, hello, it's Arnold Schwarzenegger! Oh! Hello, though. Hello, now Mr. Arnold. What a guest. What a guest. Wow, and I couldn't,
because Jason Guest and I couldn't even say you're a number one New York Times selling a number one author, you know, I mean, just, the list is just keeps going, but Jason Guest it. So Mr. Schwarzeneg and Edgar nice to meet you. Well, thank you very much for the nice introduction and I really appreciate that the build up, but I mean, it's so entertaining to listen to you guys talk.
Oh, yeah. I mean, I've very, really had conversations like that. I mean, that is Jason Mac and cheese. What about this? Mac and cheese and it's four o'clock and I'm late. It's not one of our best, but you know what? You've really brought it up. Yeah, but I mean, it's like it's wild. I mean, it's like, but the funny thing is I don't know you, Jason, and I don't know
will, even though I admire your work on television and then the movies that I've seen and the entertain me thoroughly. But Sean, I know personally. I mean, Sean is someone that I've met in the night. I think it was back in the 90s, the family of mistaken, know he was out here and some of it even helped me with Maria together decorate the house. Would I remember? Yeah, generally positive meeting. Yeah, we have very very very positive. He's a really he's a really positive guy. Well, so I love it, but I mean when I hear this this food kind of story. Yeah, it's exciting. What a drama.
You got to help. Oh my God. I ate it kind of cock. Mac and cheese. And they didn't feel good. And that's why. And this is like terrible. The world is coming to an end.
And it's like, oh, what a sad story. That's it. But more or more, I feel so sorry for him now. Thank you. I mean, I don't even know how to recuperate. Oh, no. Where do you hear what do you what do you ate the rest of the 24 hours? I wanted to start this whole interview here in the positive way, in a positive way. Then I get this beating there by the house. Well, things went from last night on 10 o'clock. I mean, Sean, what has gone on? I may
give the come. I don't know what you live now, but I mean you are the endosanulous. I'm in the same house you saw you came to visit me. Okay, good. So then is it about time you get back together again. Yes. And get that so I can go and make you one of the steaks over here so you don't get sick and tired of the food and tend to track it. Now just to come over for steak dinner, what for chicken dinner, all for something maybe vegan. Well, that's our time, Arnold. Thank you so much. Let me just say this. Having shown it's bad enough hearing what you went through last night,
but having Arnold Schwarzenegger recited back to you is one of the best things that I've ever heard in my life, because it does really put it in a different light. Like, right, it makes it sound so crazy. And how disappointed he is in your show reactions? It's just like any dad. No, no. Arnold, how long do you think Sean?
I just thought it was funny, because then you guys all went off and talked about, but with you eight, and the things that you're doing at home when you're cooking and stuff. So I said, well, maybe I've plugged in here to a cooking show or something like that. Maybe you guys have a good choice.
It's been called worse. Well, how long do you think Sean? Arnold, how long do you think Sean can get away with eating like this? Because isn't it true? As you get older, doesn't it? You're a tablism. Yeah, there were tablism slows down such that if you keep eating the same thing you ate last year, you will gain, I think it's three pounds a year if you just eat
the same thing every year. Like your metabolic rate goes down such that you've got to eliminate three pounds a year from what you eat. Is that right? Yeah, it sounds good mathematically, but you just said. But I think it's very hard to do because I can tell you for myself, I have to go on bike rides every day, I work out every day because it's very hard to kind of stop eating and to just go on severe diets like some people do, I've never done that.
So of course you develop a little bit of stomach because of that. But I think the key thing is to keep it in moderation and not to gain too much weight because otherwise it's made for you, you know, for your heart and for your health and family. Makes it sound good. You gain a little bit of stomach. That's it. Something that doesn't sound as nasty. No.
If I can ask you, because I wonder, there's so much stuff I want to talk about before we get to this, but now that we're on the subject, because like I said, you're famously known, you know, seven-time Mr. Olympia, four-time Mr. Universe, you've done it all known for your physique for many years and award winning physique. And you said that you still work out so you're riding the bike, you're doing stuff. I'm so interested. What does working out for you because you're not competing in that way anymore? What is working out now for you look like?
I'm literally, I just want to know selfishly for me. I go on a bike ride, I ride the bike on on 45 minutes to an hour a day and I work out with weights. It calls Jim, I would send him on 45 minutes a day. But very light, nothing heavy, because I had heart surgery in 1997. And then the doctors were telling me that they should stop the heavy, heavy lifting, because it's not good for your valves.
They get kind of, you know, they wipe out the sooner. And so therefore, you know, I just started lifting less weights, more reps and stuff like that. But everyone got regularly, but this, you know, as you get older, it's kind of like, how the hell do you hold on to some of the stuff that you once had? And it's really, it's tough because it's... Wait, so if you do like free weights and lift weights like that, it's bad for your valves of your heart or for your heart. If, no, not for normally for heart,
but I mean, it is when you have a valve surgery, what evolve and pulmonary valve. You don't want to put that much pressure on it, you know, when you really bench press heavy or to heavy dead lift the squats and all that stuff. You're good, John. And you put a lot of pressure on that valve and it's unnecessary.
So the idea is, is let's use less weight and therefore, you know, you don't have to switch the valve and it's unnecessary. So the idea is, is let's use less weight and therefore, you know, you don't have to switch the valve. I mean, after 23 years later, I still had to exchange it anyway and had another surgery and all that stuff, but the bottom line is you don't want to abuse it, you know, it's okay. The valve, like, everything is like a tire. You have a certain amount of miles and then it just have to switch, you know. Also, it's midsection or mind you have a tire. You have a certain amount of miles, and then it just have to switch. Also, it's midsection or a mind you have a tire. It's a whole gym. Yeah, let's get back to Gold's Gym.
Can you walk me through that process? So you walk into the gym there, you're ready to get your pump on. You've got a pump? Yeah, so you got your puncher ticket, you've got 10 more visits left. And then you get to your favorite machine, and there's some, some gemoc on that. And's he's sitting there he's running through his emails he's
still sitting on the thing and it's he's he's he's he's he's he's he's he's giving me Harry eyeball like buddy let's go I want to get in there or or you have a special section ready for it because you've been going there for years right? No I mean does the reason to approach it that way. I just always been someone sitting on the machine, or when someone works out on the machine, I just ask, you mind if I work in with you. Imagine if I go over there. While they're resting, you do your rep. Well, yeah, because everyone walks around, so what that basically means is, if you do
your set, don't just sit there, maybe while you're resting, and then you can cut in again after that, because I go from machine to machine, the machine. And so it's easy for me to just ask people if I can cut in and then what an happy to do that. So there's no problem with that. It's just a matter of attitude without saying to someone, get off the bench. I'm going to make a, sorry, so I'm just gonna just to follow up on that. I make a safe guess that you're doing well enough to have your own set of weights at the
house there. You just like to go down the goals to bond with the fellas. I have a fully equipped gym at home. Yeah. And during, you know, COVID, I trained all of the time, just at home. But I am a company queen. And so that means that I love company, whatever I do. I don't like to go out for lunch for myself, I like to eat with somebody, I don't like to go to football games or the soccer game for myself, I like to go with somebody or with a bunch of guys or people. And the same is also with working out.
I get a lot of energy when I go to a gym and see everyone else working out and sweating and training hard. It makes me inspired and then I want to work out too. So it's just a lot of sense. Yeah, because I was going to ask you like, even at this age, nobody loves to go to the gym. Now, there's not a lot of people that love to work out or exercise, but what is it that, because it's hard work, like, if I can skip it,
I'll skip it. But like, you know, what's the draw to keep doing it now and always so that you don't pop, Sean? I know, but I'm like, but to work at that, that the intensity level that you're still working out at is It's a decision. It's not that intense. It's not that intense I mean, but first of all, I love working out. Yeah, I know why because it just makes me feel good I understand I mean, I work out it makes me feel good
I always say the people say when I get up in the morning and I Bicycle down to the gym, I feel like I'm, I'm bisaking through a black and white movie and then all of a sudden when I'm finished working out and bisaking back, I feel like it's a color movie. It's a whole world, it's more colorful. I feel more positive. It's like the rainbow UCF, do you finish macaroni? She's only get on a bicycle to go to get a black and white shake.
That's the only one. We're black and white cookie. That's the last one. That's really what he's doing. That's so true. I just love it. I love the feeling that I get from that. It's addictive. So I'm addicted to working out. I have to say. So to me, it's not kind of a chore because I know why I'm doing it. I want to look half decent at my age, even though it's beautiful. It looks beautiful, aren't it? No, but the music. The beard looks gorgeous too.
Look at the beard is gorgeous. It looks really good. Thank you. But Jason, let me tell you something. First of all, I just want to let you know that you with your show OZAK. I mean, you have blown me away. You know, there's three of my favorite shows, with OZAK and Arcos and Yellowstone, the Dictator that watched.
And it was just nice coming. I mean, talking about like, Dictiv to working out, I was addicted to watching your show, Yeah, because you did such a world Unbelievable job and that it was really fantastic. You're very very nice to do the know that how much you entertain me and how much pleasure I've brought to me watching this watching this makes me shy. Thank you though. Oh Jason entertain him right now. I get I get small You want you I can I can talk in the Marty voice ready ready? Hi, it's me, I'm just talking. Oh, Marty. That's Marty.
And we will be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by Rocket Money. It's nearly 2024 and it appears that we can't buy things anymore. We can only subscribe to them, right? There are subscriptions for everything these days, from streaming services to razors, fitness programs, to pet food, even bacon of the month. It's no wonder it can feel impossible to keep tabs
on what you're paying for every month. That's why you should check out Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. With Rocket Money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button.
No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service, Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill, and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. Rocket Money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place, recommends custom budgets based on your past spending, and they money takes care of the rest. Rocket money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place, recommends custom budgets
based on your past spending, and they'll even send you notifications when you've reached your spending limits. With over 5 million users and counting, Rocket money has helped save its customers an average of $720 a year, and $1 billion in total savings so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Council your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from HelloFresh.
Whether your resolution is to save money, eat better or stress less, HelloFresh is here to help you do all three. Say hello to your most delicious year yet with fresh ingredients and chef-crafted recipes at a price you'll like delivered right to your door. Each Hello Fresh box is packed with farm fresh ingredients and everything arrives pre-portioned right to your doorstep for less hassle
and less wasted food. So you're resolved to actually sit down and eat dinner around the table, but what do you do about those nights when your schedule is packed? Turn to HelloFresh's lineup of quick and easy meals, including their 15 minute recipes designed to help minimize meal-time stress. So you know what I love?
I love the Rapid Stir Fry beef, you know why? It's rapid like me, and it's a little spicy like me. Hello, HelloFresh. Go to HelloFresh.com slash smartless free and use code SmartlessFree for free breakfast for life. One breakfast item per box while subscription is active. Get free breakfast for life and support the show while you're at it. Just go to hellofresh.com slash Smartless Free with Code Smartless Free.
Hello fresh, America's number one meal kit. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free and One Week Early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right, all your favorite, smart-less episodes can be heard on Amazon Music, Add Free, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad
Dates and Just Jack and Will, Early and Add Free, too. They also have favorites like The Daily, Pardon My Take, and Up First, all without any ads. You know what this means? Uninterrupted listings, so no more cliffhangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcasts, so we know they definitely have something for you, and it's already included in your prime membership. The list now all you need to do is go to Amazon.com slash smartless.
That's Amazon.com slash smartless, or download the Amazon Music app. It's just that easy. Alright, back to the show. the Amazon Music app, it's just that easy. All right, back to the show. So, Arnold, I mentioned in the intro all the things you've done and everything that you've done, every sort of thing that you've decided to get into, you've been successful and you started with bodybuilding. That's what initially I gather,
took you from Austria to brought you here to America and then you got into films and you were as successful as anybody could ever imagine being in in films. You're the biggest star in the world and then you got into politics and became the 38th governor of California. So cool. It's it is amazing. And I ask people
this sometimes when we've had musicians on an artist on on, just from every sort of whatever, whatever you do. And I always say, do you ever, do you have those moments where you sit back now and you go, wow, you look back where you came from, back from being a teen or being a kid in Austria. And now here you are having had this incredible run in all these different disciplines.
And do you look back and go, hey, I really accomplished a lot. Are you able to enjoy it or have perspective of it in that way? I do sometimes, but very, very rare. First of all, because I never really feel that, you know, I am that great. By any means, I always felt like I could do better.
Even when I was in my body, but in heyday, I will win the Mistolumbia contest, and then I will look in the mirror afterwards and just say to myself, how the hell did this body win? It's kind of like a nut ever satisfied. I always want to climb higher and higher and higher. And I think that's what inspires me. But the thing that I do think about quite frequently is not that I did it, but how did I do it?
Right. Because that's a really interesting thing because how did you do it? Well, it's that the principles and this is I think why and I wrote this book be useful is because the principles and the tools that they used in bodybuilding, I used the very same tools in show business and they used the very same tools when I ran for governor and then to become governor and then to be governor. So it was the same thing. It was like having a great vision
and just chasing that vision, go after it relentlessly and to work your ass off, don't listen to the naysayers, you know, just shoot for a higher course rather than no course and just go all out, you know, because this is German saying, venture on tension and talk about it in the book. So if you do something, just, and talk about it in the book. So if you do something, just go all the way. And give something back, because you mentioned that briefly,
that I never felt that I was a self-made man, that I was very fortunate that I had so much help along the way, that I felt that I have to give something back now too. And so, you know, for decades now, I have been trying to give something back to my community with working with Special Olympics and being a coach for Special Olympics or starting after school programs or being the chairman of the President's Council on Physical Fitness and Sports of the President's Bush. And all of this was all about giving back, and then eventually becoming governor,
because remember when I ran for governor, my agents kept saying to me, I don't know, this is the stupidest move that I've ever seen, because I mean, you make two million dollars to move in. I mean, it's like, you know, what the hell, you're gonna miss out on two movies a year that's $40 million, why would you do that?
And I said to myself, and I said to them, I say, hey, I made all the money because of America. I became what I am today because of America. I say America gave me the opportunity. So I don't mind putting now something back into it and giving something back. So that's the way I felt. But the key thing is, is the tools, there's tools that can make a success for. And I think I write about that very effectively in the book, and it's been really great to see the book be successful and be number one on the best solo list and all of those kind of things and selling really well internationally.
Yeah, I watched your documentary. I thought it was incredibly inspiring, and I loved that it was in three parts. It was from Austria to bodybuilding then to being an actor, then to being the governor. And one of the things you said at the beginning of the documentary, which has stayed with me was, for you said, the whole thing started out with, yeah, I don't know why, but I was given this thing that was put in my head where, if I have a vision, I can't stop until I see it through.
I don't know why, you said, I don't know why I'm like that. I just am that. And you put on why I'm, you said I don't know why I'm like that. I just am that. And you put on your wall, a picture of your favorite body builder, your inspiration. And then you kept using like vision boards and then goal lists and everything. I've been talking about that for years.
So I really connected with that. I thought it was cool. Well, thank you very much. And then it is so true that if you have a vision it's so much easier to get kind of like into it and to kind of chase it rather than let's say going to the gym and not knowing why you're at the gym other than the doctor told you you should be a little bit because it's good for your health. But you know to me I always had fun going to the gym lifting the weights, doing a next day. I was looking forward to a next to a thousand set of sit-ups and stuff like that because I knew that each one of those reps
is going to get me one step closer and winning that title. And you know, I admire this guy, Reg Park, who was Mr. Universe three times and then got into movies, into Hercules movies. And so I said to myself, well, I can do that. That's what I want to chase. That is the dream that I have, that's the division that I have. And that's what I'm trying to do. And then what you're mind was set on it, you're like, I'm getting that.
It was like a machine. I was just following it and just trying to figure out, okay, how do I train now? And I copied this guy's training methods and other people's training methods. And it just, you know, it just, but the time I was 20, I became the youngest Mr. Universe ever.
And so I realized that it was that, that having that dream that really helped me and not listening to me, they say it's because you can imagine you're 15 years old and you say to your parents, how long do we miss the universe? Right. You of course they're gonna say, well, you seek my child. Let's go to the doctor.
Right. So, they didn't believe in that dream at all, nor did anyone else as far as that goes because there was no one in Austria. Bodybuilding was an American sport. So, there was no one in Austria that ever won any competition, any kind of a Mr. Europe or Mr. Universe. So, how did you start actually bodybuilding in your 10, in the small town that you grew up?
Like, if nobody else was doing it, how did you even think of it as a possibility where you just extra strong as a kid and like it just came to you naturally? Like, no, I met a guy that was actually Mr. University, Mr. Austria. He was a bodybuilder. There was a lake where I grew up
and he came down to that lake. So that's where I grew up and he came down to that lake. So that's where I met him and he brought me to that weightlifting gym. It was not a bodybuilding gym, it was a weightlifting gym. So I became part of the weightlifting team as a member of a year after working out. They made me be part of it. And then we started competing against other towns and villages in weightlifting competition. And so that was the main thing we did was lifting heavy weights and the Olympic lifting and then at the same time I used the time to do chin ups and to do some you know curls and some body parts to build my body also at the same time.
So better was doing weightlifting, powerlifting and bodybuilding at the same time. So better was doing weightlifting, powerlifting and bodybuilding at the same time. So this is our... But the equipment was very crude, it was very simple. Only when I moved to Munich with the age of 19, I had a really well equipped gym there, and that's when I really started exploding. I mean, my body started growing really fast. Sean, you met a well equipped gym the other, right right a couple years ago. Yeah, we didn't go. It was his name James, but he went by Jim. Jimmy, Jimmy's name. He was well-equipped.
Let me ask you, Arnold, did you? Did you? I want to say, I was thinking about all the films that you've done. I was thinking about all the iconic roles, but certainly, and how much we get, we get, and people in people, like we'll stop, and people who are fans of stuff will stop you
and say like something from your movie. And I think about how many times over the years, I've personally said, or heard people say the expression, I'll be back. I can't imagine how many times you've been at a restaurant, or somewhere where somebody has gone like, you've gone like, hey, can I get a cup of coffee and they're sure? And they look back and they go, I'll be back.
And like, I mean, it must have happened a million times, right? Yeah. Well, it's really wild because I go sometimes to an event. And people will be screaming out, get to the chopper. Yeah. Which is a line from Predator. Yeah. Or put the cook it down.
Yeah. You know, it's lines from the movies, just wild, I mean, but you're right. It's funny hearing you do you. Wait, put the cookie down. Well, what was put the cookie down? You know, it was from Jingle all the way. So, it's a people repeat those lines.
The funny thing is when you read it in the script, it doesn't read like anything like a special line, it's a, but just because the way I say it, you know, get to the chopper. So then the director comes and he says, it's not chopper, Arnold. It's chopper. It doesn't earn any. I said, no, get to the chopper. You know, I say everything wrong.
It's a people think that's funny. And then they repeat the lines. But your accent is just so beautiful. It's just so iconic, and I'm so glad that it has stayed, that it has been like beat now to you by living in Southern California too long. You know, I could listen to you all day. What's that? You ran, you've run so many things at such a high level sets, our state.
What are you enjoying pointing all of those incredible leadership skills at now that some people may know about, some people might not know about, but obviously your skill set is huge. Are you enjoying pointing it out something right now? or are you enjoying letting it rest for a minute? No, no, I mean, look, I was very fortunate to be involved in all those different careers. And I learned so much in bodybuilding and how to be competitive and all that.
I learned so much in show business. It has just been a most extraordinary ride to work on orders, movies and to work with such great directors and then to go into politics and to get into becoming governor of the state of California and to sit at the capital and to learn every day something new. I mean, it's absolutely, if they imagine that when you go in there as an actor, I mean, I've never done policy. I've never got needed the details and minute details of policy. But now you're sitting there and now you're sitting, you have meetings from nine o'clock on in the morning and you sit down and always say, the nurses union comes in. And you talk about the four to one ratio versus a six to one ratio.
And you say to yourself, what are they? What are they talking about? Yeah. You don't even know. Right. And so, so then afterwards you have to have the briefings and all that stuff so you can come back and then continue that meeting later on. And then the prison got union will come in and they will talk about their problems.
Then the teachers' union comes in and talks about their problem. Then health care advocates come in and order for come in. Indian gaming drives come in and they talk about their issues and stuff. So it's like, it's literally like I said, it's a university, the capital. And I have learned stuff there in the seven years that you would never learn in any university. No way. And they teach you that, you know, how to craft all of the... Anybody listening should try to be a governor right now.
Yeah, I mean, I tell you, it's quite a challenge. It was the most pleasurable thing to serve 40 million people and to be in charge of the fifth largest economy in the world. I mean, it was really extraordinary and it wasn't easy. It was very, very tough. It was very tough on my family also because you promise to your family that you are the most important thing, but then when you become governor, then you promise to the California people that they're the most important thing.
Right. That clashes sometimes. So I would go and I would go to fundraises at night. I would be having meetings all day and I would not be around for those recitals and for the sports competitions that my kids had. And so the times when I came home and my kids would be sitting on the table where I'm sitting right now and then then we would start crying. Daddy, why won't you not at my football game?
But Daddy, why didn't you watch me, on Thursday when I was practicing soccer, and all of this kind of thing, then one after the next started crying. And I remember my wife, Maria was sitting there, she says, okay, kids, just express yourself now. Now it's the time to express yourself. I said, no, that's the last thing I'll tell you.
Wait, so anyway, so we have good wild scenes. So it's very tough to do those kind of things, but I tell you, I wouldn't exchange it for anything. I'm curious about, Arnold, you keep talking about coming here to America. I did too. I only drove 90 minutes to Buffalo from Toronto, but I, I only drove 90 minutes to Buffalo from Toronto, but I was wondering about when you first got here, when you first came to California, where did Arnold, like, where did you write on your landing car? Where did you stay? Did you have an apartment?
Did you know somebody? Did you move into a hotel? Like literally, what was the granular, like, what was that day like? When you land and you went through customs and they're like, what are you doing here? And you're like, I'm gonna be bodybuilder and then I'm gonna be a movie star and then I'm gonna be governor, look out. And like, how did that day go?
So I was Mr. Universe. I just wanted to Mr. Universe competition in Ken for the second time at the age of 21. And this guy by the name of Joe Weeda, who was then kind of the Zah of bodybuilding. He was the publisher of the bodybuilding magazines in the years of weight distribution, kind of an equipment distribution company, food supplement company, and he brought me to the United States.
And so he sent me out to Los Angeles because this is where the best gymnasiums were. And he asked some of his friends, look, why don't you go and find an apartment for honor and then mean them let him stay there at your house. And so I stayed at someone's house for three days. Then in the meantime, they found an apartment for me in North Hollywood. And there I started training then at Vince's gym which was one of the great bodybuilding gyms where a lot of the champions trained. And then eventually I moved over to the Sanamonica, the Venice where Gord's gym
was and then I started training there. What was your English light? What was your English light at that time? Oh it sucked. It totally sucked. I mean, it was like in a school English, I was a few times in England for both posing exhibitions and strong men acts and stuff like that. So I was able to practice a little bit the English, but I couldn't read a newspaper. I couldn't really understand television.
I had a friend, a Jewish friend that spoke German, but the name of Ari Zeller, who was a bodybuilding photographer, and he would translate for me when we watched the news. And I remember when there were discussions in press conferences with Nixon, many ran for president and to Humphrey. And he would always translate. And he was a real liberal, this guy.
And when I said, I like what Nixon said, he says, I don't be absurd, I don't know. This is absurd. He's a fool. Don't even listen to him. So he would always get mad at me about that. But in any case, so I could not really understand. I was not with the program at all.
But one thing I remembered, and that was, it was now Thanksgiving. And it was, I did not know what Thanksgiving was. And the guy came over to me in the gym and he says, what are you doing Thanksgiving? And I said, what is Thanksgiving? He says, well, it's a special holiday. And all this, he says, well, we eat a lot of food. He says, if you don't have anything to do,
if you don't have anyone to spend the day with, I want to invite you to my house and so this guy built Drake invited me to his house and there it is unbelievable Thanksgiving dinner the first Thanksgiving dinner the following day when the word got around the gym that I was new and that was kind of helpless here and and all that they came over to my apartment and they brought dishes, they brought silverware, pillowcases, pillows, and all kinds of, even a black and white TV. One guy gave me the old antenna like it used to be. And then a little radio, a wooden box, the radio for my nightstand on the side of the bed. So I mean, the generosity that I experienced was so staggering and so touching.
I would never forget that this is why today, I was away at the Hollandbeck Center. You know, for the 30 second time, in the sense I've been in America, to give out Turkey, because I donate to Turkey for the poor people in East LA and So we handed out hundreds of turkeys to this poor people that sometimes can't even afford to have a nice turkey dinner Just because I remember that day how this guy included me
So I always wanted to do the same thing back to the American people to put people to people that needed. That's great. We'll be right back. Hey smartless listener, let's talk about a destination that defines paradise. Naples, Marco Island, and the Everglades, Florida's Paradise Coast. In vision over 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline ranging from secluded Keywaden Island to luxury beachfront resorts, perfect for every beach lover, whether you're playing in the surf, soaking up the
sun, or enjoying a gorgeous sunset, this destination offers it all. Explore the natural wonders of Florida's paradise coast featuring mangroves. Mangroves? I'm in. Estuaries and a plethora of outdoor adventurers from guided swamp walks and kayaking to boating, fishing diving, and championship golf courses, this paradise caters to diverse interests. Seeking luxury, Naples delivers with high-end shopping
at Fifth Avenue South and Mercado. Rejuvenate amid ciprus trees and golf breezes at world-class spots and indulgent co-stair services for a truly luxurious experience. Culinary delights await with fresh from the golf seafood, sustainable stone crab season from October to May, and exclusive chef's table encounters. Don't just listen, experience it.
For the finest of everything Florida has to offer, only Paradise will do. Plan your trip today at ParadiseCost.com slash Smartless. Smartless is supported by Hydro. So for me time is is everything, right? We're all scrunched for time. We have things, we have families, we have work, we have whatever, everything. So I'm looking for a fast workout that I know works.
And with Hydro in 20 minutes, it's a better use of my time to get a full body workout, which is what I've been looking for. Hydro is the best. It's a state-of-the-art at-home, rowing machine designed by rowers that delivers the ultimate full body workout. How ultimate? It works 86% of your muscles. I'm talking arms, legs, core,
and it only takes 20 minutes. I'm in, right? Rowing with Hydro is low impact, so low risk of injury. The workouts are taught by Olympians and world-class athletes who are great coaches for any fitness level. Okay, so I literally just got mine delivered, so I'm getting started.
But I love it because it's in my home. I love the great programs and the videos, but I like it because it actually makes me feel like I'm accomplishing something. You know what I mean? I actually feel like I'm rowing somewhere and I can't wait to get there. And also when someone comes by my house, I show it to them and they're like, ooh, how do I get one? Join the growing, growing community at Hydro and make sure you let them know Smartless sent you. Head over to Hydro.com and use Code Smartless to save up to $500 off your Hydro.
That's h-y-d-r-o-w.com. Code Smartless to save up to Audible for their support. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. There's an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from best sellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, and more. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog of thousands of titles. I'm currently listening to my friend Tina Fey's book Bossy Pants. I love Tina, she's a friend, and what's great about it, she's narrating it. It's so funny, I read it a long time ago, but I'm listening to it again, it's so good.
New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Well, with such meager beginnings, I mean, the leap from there to thinking that you could actually be the governor of the state, when do you remember the first time you thought, well, maybe that's something I could do. Was it during Reagan's administration, you thought, well, hang on, here's an actor who
became a governor, and I'm an actor, so why can't I get it? Was that the linkage that was the first time it felt plausible? No, not really, because I knew at that time there was stories written that people from the outside come in. There was stories about Eisenhower, who was a general, who was not a politician at all, and I can present it in the United States. There were people that were basketball players. John Glendon eventually became a senator, he was an astronaut, norris. So that was not even though it was great to see that someone from entertainment, because everyone always laughed at that, they were from Hollywood, how can anyone become governor,
when he's from Hollywood, or how can he become president, if you're from Hollywood, an act and stuff like that. So there were those kind of conversations, of course, but I think what really inspired me was, maybe a little bit of that, but also, like I said, hanging out with the Shrivers, with the Kennedys, then becoming the chairman of the president's council and physical fitness and sports
on the president Bush Senior in 1990. He made me chairman. And so when I hung out with him and he invited me to camp David, I mean, so many times. So I really spend a lot of time with him and we organized a great American workout and that he had been sitting on several of the meetings. I up in camp David and also in the White House. And so all of that really inspired me, and I said, I'm just, there is such a wonderful job to bring people together like he does and to make this a better place, a better country, a better state, or whatever.
So I got inspired with that. And just the mere fact that you were hanging out with somebody who was president, it sort of made it feel like, well, I know this guy's a human being. He's a man just like me. It's sort of, I'm sure it took care of some of the sort of debilitating mystique that's.
Made it through the right size a little bit. Yeah. And also the compliment that he always gave me is, you know, you are not even good nose for this stuff, for power, the exact conceit, the interest that it in all this stuff. But I was in the middle of my movie career then. Yeah.
It was just, you know, just preaching over for the first time, things that you guys are so good at, which is comedy, you know, because I was an action hero, I was doing Terminator and Predator and Running Man and Red Heat in all those movies, and they keep grossing more money. But then I had this urge to say, I gotta do comedy.
And you were a hilarious. It stuck here and doing action. And then everyone said, forget say, I got to do comedy. And you were hilarious. It stuck here and doing action. And then everyone said, forget it, it's not going to happen. But then Ivan Rybman, who was the producer, I mean, the director of Ghostbusters, he said to me, I do it. I'm going to develop a project for you. And he did. There was twin twins.
It was twin twins. Yeah, and so we did that in 1988. We had with President Bush, a presidential premier at the Kennedy Center in 1988 in December. And the movie went through the roof. And so it was the first movie actually that made over $100 million domestically. So it was made a hundred and twenty eight million dollars. So it was really something that was I was excited about. So I was kind of like in the middle of climbing that ladder you know it was just two thirds up a mountain Everest and I still had to go climb one third more and I felt like it's so then I did terminated too and so that was I was not really at that stage where I said okay I'm gonna run now.
No but I should it should be pointed out. I just want to sideburn, because you're being quite modest about it. You wanted to do a comedy, and to the point that the studio wasn't sure, tell me if I've got this right or wrong, the studio wasn't sure that you were such a bankable actionist or they weren't sure that you would be a bankable,
you'd be able to open a comedy. And you took a risk on yourself, which is what you've been known to do. And you took nothing upfront, and you just took a percent, you just took a big piece of the box office. And twins was your biggest payday ever by far because it was such a massive hit.
And you bet on yourself, which is so fucking great, because you've been betting on yourself your whole life and it paid off. Am I right about that? You're absolutely right, very well researched, I have to say, you know, all the details, I love that, but I mean, that the bottom line was the studio space,
not only didn't believe that it could open a movie in the comedy, but they also said to me, they said to me, I wrote, tell me now why I would go and invest in a comedy when we are making all this money now with your action movies. What do you think? We're stupid. And as I said, no, no, no, no, I totally understand it. So we had to figure out a way to kind of make it more
appealing to them. And so with Ivan Rythman then said was what we should all do is we should make the movie for 16 and a half million dollars and not take a salary He says I won't take a salary Then it doesn't take a salary and you don't take a salary, I don't. And what we do is in return, we go and get 40% ownership together. We renegotiated and we renegotiated and they made it 37.5% because Tom Pollack was a good friend of Ivan Ryattman and he felt kind of he got a beating from the studio to make the deal. So we gave him a 2.5% cut and we made 37 and half but you absolutely right. That made more money for me than anything because worldwide the movie crossed over $220,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000,000, and rentals too. Yeah, you know, it was, you know,
there was a lot of things that we've never sold the movie to the earplanes, when they sold it to the TV, to network, and to all the different, and I'm still getting residuals now. That's amazing. That's amazing. That's the way it's about.
It's worrying about you. But I mean, anyway, the bottom line is that I was still, now I was like growing, I was doing kindergarten, cop after that, junior and true lies, which in Cameron, and so they were all kind of like comedies and action and all that stuff. But then what do you think about this troublemaker, son-in-law of yours? This fellow is Chris Pratt. Yeah, Pratt.
I mean, this guy, we know him, we know Pratt. He's a little, he's an outlaw, he's a troublemaker, he's a,blemaker. He's a great friend of ours. We laugh with them. We laugh with them. He talks very highly of you. It gets me a little jealous. It sounds like you guys have a great sort of family sort of rhythm going over there with getting together for dinners and vacations and hanging out It just sounds like a really good thing. You're right. I mean, it is so much fun When he and my daughter comes over here to the house and They come over like last week to come over one Saturday
It's seven in the morning to help me feed the animals It's seven in the morning to help me feed the animals. So, you know, which of course I have a miniature pony, I have a miniature donkey, I have a pig, I have three dogs. I mean, there's this animals all over the place. And so of course in the morning I always feed them. So I told the cat, and I said, get up and bring the kids over. Do you feed them like many donuts and many,
do they have many food? Or you just give them smaller portions? No, no, it's just a smaller portion. Some of them don't need smaller portions. They'll already give a smaller portion to a pig. Yeah, it's kind of a bitch now. Sean? All the time.
I mean, it's like when you let it out, it goes out in the grass and then it's grass all day long. There comes in the kitchen. And everything that he sees in the kitchen, the traps down. The pig, wait, the pig comes in the kitchen? Yeah, the pig sleeps. It's a house pig. The house pig.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yeah, yeah, yeah, it depends what the way you deal with it, the animals. But my dogs come into the house, the donkey comes into the house. Come on. He comes into the house. This is what they're meaning. Yeah. I get it.
The many, but the many, even if it's a regular horse, I wear every bring, brought, I had a pison. What is it? Coming to my kitchen here, a pison. You know, the big pison. Oh, pison? The pison, yeah. I mean, I mean, so I opened up the double door here
because we have every year year a poker tournament here to raise money for after-school programs. And this last October we raised $7 million with them. So the theme was October Fest. Everyone had to wear leather hoes and the women wear turundles and all that stuff. And I have, as part of the entertainment, I have all this animals coming over here. So they just, I said, we had this by standing outside. So I said, let me just try it because it's so it's on the online. When you go online, you can see there's a farmer that raised his
bison from the time he was like a little baby and then fed it with the bottle and milk and all this stuff. And then he's still coming, he's still coming into the kitchen at his farmer's house here to widen the door and increase the height of the door. So I tried to do the same thing. I opened up the door and I brought this pie into the kitchen. I mean, if this side of a bitch would have gone crazy, would have destroyed the whole house because it was so big. But I mean, so yeah, I think it's cool when you bring animals into the kitchen
and into the house and that they roam around. So earlier, I think it was a question Jason had. When I was going, you know, you climb this mountain of achieving this bodybuilding greatness, you climb this massive mountain of being a global international movie star. The biggest movie star we've ever had. Yeah, ever.
Nobody had done it that big before Arnold. Right. And then you climbed this third mountain of being the governor of California. Is there a fourth mountain? Is there another chapter like, you know what, there's one more thing I really want to do. I have my eyes set on blank.
He's trying to get you to musical theater. Just don't take the bait. That's funny, very funny. But I mean, you know, the thing, we sometimes kind of have a vision that we go after, like I did with bodybuilding, and like I did with show business. But my vision was not to become governor. Only later on,
all of a sudden, when we had a recall, all of a sudden I kind of got obsessed with the whole idea. Yeah. And I ran for governor. But I mean, now my vision is kind of like, I want to go and help people become more successful. I somehow got into these motivational speeches because I started giving a motivation speech when a commencement speech at universities and then all of a sudden that kind of went wild, went to the spread like wildfire and people started writing to me, why don't you write a book and all that stuff. And so I kept in doing motivation speeches all over the world, kind of like the ex-presidents to the Gondas speaking circuit,
you know, you make some good money with that, and you can reach a lot of people. And out of that came then this book. So this is the new thing now that I'm really into is, how do we help people? Because there's so many people that are unhappy. There's so many people that are on drugs to get happier.
There's so many people that are lost, that don't have a real goal or a mission. And I just feel very, very strongly that when we have a mission, when you get up in the morning with a mission, and when you get up in the morning with a mission and when you get up in the morning with a purpose Yeah, there'd be no what we're going after what we're chasing no matter how hard it is Because you mentioned earlier, but this is really hard to go in the gym of the workout I look forward to that because I feel that the brain is kind of like a muscle the more Resistance we give it and the more we struggle the better we get and the stronger we get. And I think that's what it's all about. So we don't win about that and everything, but we can confront kind of challenges.
And confront the white bouts, the losses, because you fail. I failed many times and movies, I failed in politics many times, but you know, I always kind of get up and dust myself off and get stronger with that. So I want to teach that to other people. How do they get happy and how do they become what's successful? And that's what the book be useful is all about. Yeah, be useful.
Seven tools for life, which is amazing. And I would just say Arnold on the side, Jason just texted me and he said, do they make dumbbells in a one pound? Do they make it in the one pound? And I was like, what, that's crazy. But I mean, he literally, it's been- I like to do a lot of reps.
You know, it's so sad. I don't believe that Jason was asking that question. No, it's true. Jason was probably asking the opposite question in saying, do they make dumbbells, they're down in 50 pounds? All I do is cardio. I used, I lived a lot of, I go to the gym a lot.
You can't tell the lighting's not great here, but I do go to the gym a lot for, you know, you should just know. Okay, the last thing I want to ask you, Arnold, I mean, honestly, there's just such an endless well of stuff that you've done that I'd love to talk to you about. Your friendship, potential friendship, but certainly working professional relationship with Jim Cameron. When did you first meet James Cameron? What was that moment?
Because you guys obviously had an incredible run together. Yeah, I mean, Jim, at the time when I met him, he only has done one movie. And he pitched, you know, he talked to me about Terminator, the first Terminator. And I was actually going for the interview to play Rees, to play the heroic character. And through some kind of a, I showed a little bit too much enthusiasm about the character of Terminator and kept saying to him, whoever placed that character because I think Ocee Simpson was cast, not yet a contract sign, but was cast already to play Ocee to terminator. So he was trying to talk me into playing the
Terminator and I said, now I want to play Reese. And he says, no, you understand the Terminator and I said, now I want to play Reese. And he says, no, no, you understand the Terminator. You talk about that he has to walk like a machine and he has to kind of turn his head like a machine, he has to kind of like prep, take the guns apart and putting them back together, blindfolded, notice, this is all great stuff. He says, that's exactly what he has to do. And so anyway, he talked me into it. I played the Terminator. And the rest is history, you know, the movie was highly successful. And it was, of course, very, very smartly written. I mean, he himself described, he himself described it as an almost an indie film, because he wrote it in his part of it in his car. And that was weird. It was wild. Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely. But anyway, so then we did the Terminator 2 that became the highest-grossing movie of He wrote it in his part of it in his car and that was a weird, it was wild. Yeah, no, absolutely. But anyway, so then we did a terminated tool that became the highest-grossing movie of the year and we did the true lies and that also made like $150 million worldwide. So it was really, I had a great, great streak of movies that we did together and he was an excellent director, very demanding. I have to say, and very, very, very smart. He's one of those guys that he wants to film something a certain way, but there is no equipment around like that,
no camera that could do that, then he would develop it. He would develop the camera. You know, when he went down and he developed this kind of submarine to go down the ocean to the Titanic and to look inside the Titanic, he went with his vehicle, inside the Titanic to go and to really be able to make the film Titanic in the best possible way. So that's the way he is. He just develops it.
I mean, he's just a genius. And in everything he does, he also helped me a lot with the environmental stuff that I did here in California and worldwide. We have given speeches about the environment, not that he's really into the reducing of pollution. And to clean up the world and make the world a healthy place, he's also very heavily into a vegan. He's a vegan for the last 10 years already, and hasn't eaten any meat because he feels like the producing of livestock creates the pollution, 28% of the pollution comes.
He shouldn't come to your house then. Yeah, we can run over by advice. I actually got off meat, at least 70% of the meat, I do eat steaks every so often, still in the finish and it's all in stuff like that. But I've reduced my meat intake considerably. It's much healthier because of it. I could listen to you say son of a bitch
and venerate central all. I know. I know. I'm going to get to the chopper. I know. I know. We have, you're a very busy man. You have a lot of animals that you need to tend to.
Go see them. But thank you for taking the time and talking to us and so much success and congratulations on everything, including your book, which is just amazing, be useful, seven tools for life that's out now. Just so happy for you. And again, just such an honor to have you here with us. Thank you for doing this.
Thanks for doing it. This guy is Jason Sean Will. I just want to tell you that it was such a pleasure to be interviewed by three brilliant actors like you. And so it was an honor for me to do this. And I had a great time. I really enjoyed every minute of it. So thank you very much. Thank you very, very much. Thank you. Thank you. Bye bye. Be good. See you. Bye. Wow. How cool was that? Nice guest, Willie. Wow. Right. And that's pretty cool. Sean, you know, I actually kind of didn't bring this up. And I'm sure we have lots of fans who I was because I see sometimes in the comments, like, well, you got to mention that you know the thing and you said to know it all, but I did
meet him once at your house. Oh, that's right. You're here to go. Remember you had that poker tournament in your backyard? Yeah, I was 1999 or 2000 or something like that. Something crazy. Yeah, it was crazy. Yeah, he came over and he, yeah.
No, 2004. 2004, oh, wow. I had it. I think you could make a real argument that that's the biggest star we've ever had on this show. I mean, like you name me one person, more recognizable, more famous, or the biggest sort of like, the quintessential star, you know, like that's known that every country he goes to. Like from the time that the three of us were teenagers into our into our late
20s. Yeah. And if anybody had said to us, like, who's the biggest movie star in the world? You'd say for sure. It's crazy. What a career that guy is. Unbelievable. I know. Pretty remarkable. He's very inspiring from some lake in Austria because like, you know, the most world famous bodybuilder ever, then the governor, two times governor. Two times governor. Yeah, of this state, as he said, the fifth largest economy, blah, blah, blah. He's just, and a guy who really was right down the middle of his politics.
Yeah, you know. It's just incredible. And everything he did, and yeah, it's pretty remarkable to watch. And like you said, Jason, very humble beginnings, like doing like strong man competitions against the next town. Yeah. Like not even bodybuilding. And, but, you know, and I know he doesn't work out in the same way these days, but I bet
you he's still got some pretty good looking. Bye. See you. See you. See you. See you. See you. See you. I bet you he's still got some pretty good looking. Bye! Bye, Seth! Oh, that's not good. I'll do that one with God. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grantary.
If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundri Plus in the Wundri app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com-slave-survey. called over the top and we cover the biggest topics in sports and pop culture using royal rumble rules. That means we'll start with two stories. Toss one out on its ass and dive into the other stories with ruthless aggression. Oh, but it never stops because every 90 seconds after that.
While God, whose music is that? Another story comes down to the ring. Rinse and repeat until we arrive at the one most important thing on planet Earth that week. Follow over the top on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to over the top early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus. For the record, this is not a wrestling podcast. No, no, but it is inspired by wrestling. Isn't everything inspired by wrestling, Beetle? Fair point.
Yeah! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.